Speaker 1: I want to welcome you back to The
David Pakman Show. I am Jesse Dallimore filling
in for David while he is out, hopefully resting
and relaxing this week. Let's talk about Kevin
McCarthy. Let's talk about Congress in general
and the budget battle that we're facing and the
the debt ceiling battle that we're facing. We
can we can set aside the fact that Republicans
approved and then the debt ceiling fight. They
went through it and they approved a debt ceiling
increase for four, three times under Donald Trump
when Donald Trump was president. Three times.
No problem. Oh, yeah, it's not a big deal. That's.
It's the responsible thing to do when there's a
Republican in office. But when a Democrat is in
office, then, oh, no, no. We we need to shut down
the government. If you don't bend and bow to our
demands again, because it's not about governance,
it's not about what's best for the full faith
and credit of the United States of America.
It's not about any of that. It's about scoring
political points. It's about chaos in the system.
And Kevin McCarthy was just at the White House
and had a meeting with Joe Biden. He comes out
of the meeting and is peppered with questions
for several minutes by reporters. And there's
one question in particular that I really want
to hone in on, because, one, Kevin McCarthy is
woefully inadequately suited for this job. He's
not real bright, He's not very articulate. And he
just generally kind of fumbles around in the dark
for an answer. The second clip will really, really
illustrate that. But let's start with this first
question. I don't know how well you're going to be
able to hear the audio, so I'll just I'll I'll ask
the question then. Then you'll be able to piece it
together when you hear the reporter ask it. It's
what credibility do conservatives and Republicans
have when they talk about reducing the debt and
deficits, when in the previous administration,
when Republicans had control of both the White
House and Congress, they ran up the bill.
And this there's no way to disagree with
the premise of the questions. This is fact.
When Republicans have been in office, they run
away, deficits go crazy. The national debt soars.
Now, these are metrics that you can argue
whether they're important or not. I don't
generally think a large national
debt makes that much difference.
But. Let's set that as well. Just set that
aside. The fact of the matter is Donald Trump,
with his irresponsible, unpaid for tax cuts,
wasn't able to fund the government and all the
spending that needed to be done. And his tax
cuts resulted in that they were promised that
they would be paid for. They promised it would
spark the economy so much that it would just be
cash hand over fist into the Treasury. The fact
of the matter, the data, the the actual reality
is that there were 1,000,000,000,001 and a half
trillion dollar deficits, $1,000 billion deficits,
and one and a half and $1,500 billion deficits
every year of Donald Trump's. Presidency. Making
it so that Donald Trump is responsible personally
as his administration for 25% of our overall
national debt. And the goof was only in office
for four years. It pales in comparison. It makes
Reagan's administration and the the wild, rampant
spending look like child's play. But let's let's
get to this question from the reporter and listen
to Kevin McCarthy's answer, and we'll talk about
it on the other side. Speaker What credibility
do conservatives and Republicans have when.
Speaker 2: They talk about
what you're thinking about?
That's a great question.
Speaker 3: This
administration. When Republicans take control,
both the White House and Congress ran up the bill.
Speaker 2: Okay. Let's just go by the the shear
facts and figures. All right. So Republicans
were in the majority for eight years and then the
Democrats came in the majority for the last four
years. So in the last four years, the Democrats
have increased discretionary spending by 30%,
over $400 billion when the Republicans were
in majority twice that long. The discretionary
spending didn't go up $1. It went down 10 billion.
So I think that the credibility last easily with
the Republicans, if you want to argue about from a
place where the president, the the past president,
if you continue down the same path this presidency
will spend have put us in debt much greater than
before. So, look, I'm not in a place that I'm
going to point fingers. I'm in a place of being
the speaker of the House. My role right now is to
make sure we have a sensible, responsible ability
to raise the debt ceiling, but not continue
this runaway spending. This is a moment in
time that for all American households, every
family does this, every business does this,
every state government, every county government
when they have spent too much. Take Lorraine back.
Look where waste is at. Look where investments
would be better and sit down and talk in an
adult fashion. That's the conversation I just had
with the president. And that's the conversation I
want to continue so we can come to an agreement.
Speaker 1: Why didn't you have those conversations
while Donald Trump was president? Why didn't
you identify those areas that are now so
important that you're willing to shut down
the government over them? Kevin McCarthy.
And all of the ancillary nonsense that
you bring up doesn't defeat the points
that when Donald Trump was in
office prior to becoming president,
when he spoke to Bob Woodward with The
Washington Post and said the audacious
claim that he was going to pay off the entirety
of the United States debt inside of eight years.
And instead jacked it up, went crazy spending not
raising enough money into the Treasury through tax
cuts that, by the way, didn't sunset. They sunset
it for the middle class. They didn't sunset.
For the rich. It's just it's hypocrisy and
it's excuse making and he stumbling and
bumbling and trying to find a point.
And only Republicans fall for this.
Because it's it's nonsense. And it's propagated
this propaganda by right wing media outlets. Now,
getting back to the point earlier about how he is
unfit to be speaker, that he's not qualified or
capable of being speaker. Listen. Listen, there's
a lot of word solid politicians in Washington.
Many come to mind, one not in Washington. Maybe
chief among them is Sarah Palin. But there's a
lot of them out there. George W Bush was famous
for his word salad. This sentence I challenge you
to to explain to me in my feeble brain what
the hell he is talking about. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: I believe in hearing both
perspectives like anything else. Be it business,
be that family, be the relationships that you can
find common ground. There's nothing in there but
me walking away that does not believe. At the
end of the day, we can come to an agreement.
Speaker 1: Did you did you catch that? Because
I sure didn't. I have no idea what he's talking
about. Let's read it again. There's nothing
in there but me walking away that does not
believe. At the end of the day, we can come
to an agreement. There's nothing in there but
me walking away that does not believe. At the
end of the day, we can come to an agreement.
I make it make sense. Please. It's not. It's
not a rhetorical question. Please. It's not a
rhetorical request. Please make it make sense.
He's just not fit. He's not ready. I mean,
we have many damaging speakers of the House
over the course of the history of our country,
even more modern times. Newt Gingrich comes to
mind. But they were articulate. They could find
a complete sentence with with. With one hand.
And and Kevin McCarthy is just incapable. And
it's it's going to hurt you. It's going to hurt
America overall, because he's going to allow the
the the inmates to run the prison. He already is
letting that happen with Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
And while he's running over the White House
to to make a big to do about his negotiation.
Nothing's getting done other than some
real damage that may be irreparable.